toi tu sais jouer les psy très dur qui
veulent entrer un bon acteur un voile
aérogares est ce que tu sais jouer voilà
si tu peu comme si tu pourrais d'une
balle comme lui est ce que tu pourrais
rejouer la scène vue sur moi dessus la
mort du mois résidant en l'air mais en
l'air les deux connards reconnu faisait
yakalelo la demoiselle fait ça c'est ça
tu es tu donnes tu dois des droits de
vote
tu me tues voyants sont la porte en
importe qu'elle soit n'importe quoi même
mais non à lui même associé patrick delà
les défauts d'un simple téléphone et
humeur
vas-y
[Rires]
mais tire moi tu veux rire en mourant s
est très dur de jouer le ballon
pourquoi faire du cinéma l'année
prochaine c'est vrai vous l'essayez
micro là il fallait aller vite vite
belge a dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon